remember when joe biden said we wouldn't
leave anyone behind in afghanistan
americans should understand that troops
might have to be there beyond august
31st no americans should understand that
we're going to try to get it done before
august 31 but if we don't
the troops if we don't we'll determine
at the time who's left
and
and if they're american forces if
there's american citizens left we're
going to stay to get them all out
he had to be prodded to say that but
shouldn't he be forced to back up his
words that's what senator josh hawley
found out that in fact the president did
not live up to that statement at all
isn't it true that you left americans
behind on august the
31st there are americans there were
americans there were still in uh in
afghanistan ncr
yes the answer is yes how hard is it to
say yes you left hundreds if not
thousands behind here to react to
lieutenant colonel scott mann has been
trying to get him out himself former
green beret and co-founder of task force
pineapple and sean parnell retired
decorated infantry captain and
pennsylvania senate candidate i'll start
with you scott of course we left people
behind you wouldn't have to scramble
give up your job put together a task
force and try to get them out as a
retired guy did that outrage you
well i mean
it's frustrating i'll tell you that
brian and thanks for having me on but i
think what's frustrating to so many of
our retired volunteer veterans right now
is that there are still thousands of
at-risk afghans who are being hunted and
executed right now look there are
partnered special operations forces from
the commandos and afghan special forces
and afghan interpreters that fought to
the last bullet the last bullet and now
they're being hunted down and we're
we're just focused on anything that we
can do to work with the government and
the private sector to get them out any
way that we can scott
it's unbelievable sean parnell because
you fought over there you put your life
on the line over there your friends lost
their lives over there and now you have
the people that allied who are close to
you running for their lives we don't
even have a plan or as senator
blumenthal requested some type of
czar in charge of getting people out
one by one we have to do it one by one
yeah it's an unbelievable slap in the
face by the way to anybody who served
this country for the last 20 years to
have joe biden trot out to the podium
and call the withdrawal or surrender
really in afghanistan an extraordinary
success and and joe biden by the way he
intended to lie and deceive the american
people from day one on afghanistan look
no further than his conversation with
president ghani of afghanistan uh in
late july where he tried to convince
president ghani to tell the world that
the taliban was not as strong as
as we knew that they were in exchange
for military aid uh from the united
states of america so joe biden intended
to deceive the american people all along
and and as a result we're seeing our
direct this disastrous surrender in
afghanistan we've got americans left
behind thousands of our allies left
behind one of our final acts in
afghanistan was killing an aid worker in
seven children and and what blows me
away beyond all of this is that no one
has been held accountable
it is unbelievable to me that the only
person that's been held accountable is a
lieutenant colonel in the marine corps
who is front towards enemy that simply
called for accountability in a very
professional way he's in jail tonight
and that is absolutely unacceptable yeah
until his trial comes up we hope to talk
to his parents tomorrow
scott i know you're working with the
defense department you don't want to
bernie bridges i understand that but
today defense was saying the state's
handling it you know the state
department's been no help we got 10 000
people who have a reason to say they
helped america and legitimate americans
what's your plan of action what is your
message to washington
yeah i would just say that we've
actually got tens of thousands
of at-risk afghans right now brian that
that have no way out if the private
sector and the public sector doesn't
continue to work together on this my
concern is that the only conversation on
this right now is what went wrong and i
believe me i believe that conversation
has to happen and i think it will happen
and and you all are pressing that but
what i also worry about is what are we
doing right now i know to get out the
tens of thousands that we made a
commitment to and that's where i think
we need to continue not just the
conversation but meaningful action that
shows how we're getting them out moving
them any way that we can and right now
that seems to be slipping away uh in the
news and in the conversation and that
worries me more than anything yeah we
got to get we got to hear about people
getting out and i want to have people
sitting next to either side of you and
you telling me how they did it and the
land bridge that worked but we're not
there yet sean purnell do me a favor uh
win your election get on the armed
services committee and hold these guys
and these women accountable uh you can
bet that i will brian one of my top
priorities in the senate will be
reforming how we pick select and promote
general officers because right now i
think at the top echelons of our
military we have too many leaders that
are concerned with their bow and not
their wake and we need a recognition
that service is the core of of
everything that we do in the military
and never leaving americans behind yeah
my message is to the next chairman of
general and chief of staff when bob
woodward calls let us go let it go to
voicemail please thanks guys appreciate
it scott great work sean keep working i
know you're getting a lot of calls too
thanks hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else